[Musique]
alors l'habitat du futur
on a tous dans la tête une idée de
caisse que sa maison de nos rêves parce
que c'est une maison en compagne ou bien
un magnifique atik au centre ville ou
encore une villa au bord de la mer mais
au fond qu'est ce qu'on a vraiment
besoin
on a besoin d'un toit on a besoin en
fête de l'eau à boire et de l'eau pour
se laver et un peu d'électricité pour
voir la nuit donc quand j'imagine le
superbe pratique au centre ville avec
son jacuzzi vue sur les étoiles
je me pose la question de caisse qui est
vraiment essentiel est qu est ce qui est
accessoire dans la société d'aujourd'hui
l'économie l'inr nous d'y produire
consommer est jeté et avec ça on épuise
nos ressources naturelles
en effet il ya une semaine la suisse
enfin le vvf annoncé que la suisse avait
consommé toutes ses ressources pour
l'année 2010 est donc en moins de quatre
mois alors qu'est ce qu'on fait existe
l'économie circulaire dont l'idée est
basé sur le principe des quatre aires
réduire déjà notre consommation
recycler réutiliser refabriquer ou
restitués à la nature ce qu'il vient
avec des systèmes qui sont comme les
systèmes pour la gestion des eaux par
exemple on peut avoir ces principes
circulaire est là à l'aube en fait de
commencer mon projet de master en
architecture je me suis dit que si je
pouvais construire j'aimerais construire
des solutions pour le futur et là on m'a
présenté le solar decathlon donc au
début des études
architecture on doit choisir un atelier
le solar decathlon
vous en avez peut-être jamais entendu
parler j'étais comme vous donc on m'a
expliqué l'idée c'est des étudiants un
groupe d'étudiants qui va construire une
maison qui marche uniquement à l'énergie
solaire
et ça c'est pour le côté solar decathlon
c'est parce qu'en fait cette maison et
ensuite testé sur dix critères
l'architecturé l'ingénierie l'énergie la
santé le confort communication et bien
d'autres encore nous quitter en fait
c'est que des étudiants vont aller
construire une maison qui marche
uniquement à l'énergie solaire
et là je me suis dit ça a l'air cool
pour une fois on peut construire quelque
chose
en vrai et présenter ça alors une équipe
s'est formé une équipe avec des
étudiants qui viennent de l'épée fall de
l' acia tri bourg de la head de genève
et de l'uni de fribourg
c'était un peu comme venir des quatre
coins du monde on avait des étudiants en
architecture en ingénierie en
communication ou encore en économie et
puis ensemble on a développé une idée et
on a présenté ça on a soumis sa en fait
au département de l'énergie qui organise
la compétition sert à décathlon aux
états unis et on a été sélectionné
donc pour aller présenter cette maison
aux états unis à denver en octobre 2017
lors de la compétition sera décathlon
ben là ça nous a mis un peu la pression
parce qu'on s'est dit combien on est
l'équipe suisse et on va aller présenter
ça aux états unis donc il faut quand
même qu'on trouve un projet cool quoi du
coup qu'est ce qu'on va faire
est ce que la suisse a besoin pour
développer des villes plus durable
alors on a un peu étudié en suisse on à
la loi sur l'aménagement du territoire
qui nous dit que le territoire c'est
aussi une ressource limitée et on a
aussi l'idée de la transition
énergétique dont les prochaines
votations
donc il faut qu'on baisse notre
consommation d'énergie
mais comment on fait ça et là notre
projet le nez bob donc number pour
neighbourhood en anglais qui veut dire
en pâte quartier et hub pour centre donc
notre idée c'est de construire en fait
une maison qui va transformer tout un
quartier
cette maison sera un lieu de rencontre
et de partage pour les habitants ça
permettra aussi à chacun en fait d'agir
de trouver des alternatives sur cette
thématique que l'on a défini qui nous
concernent au quotidien donc à la
nourriture ni matériaux énergie la
gestion des eaux la gestion des déchets
la mobilité et la biodiversité
ok là je vous ai tous perdu on veut me
dit bon concrètement qu'est ce que nous
raconte donc
imaginons ensemble qu'est ce que c'est
le nombre passer ça qu'on a fait donc
imaginons que l'onem bob et posez-la
dont un quartier de villas et justement
dans ce quartier plusieurs personnes en
fat ont envie d'installer des panneaux
solaires sur leur maison mais et ça va
vraiment comment faire ils savent pas
combien ça coûte
comment ça marche et du coup une
entreprise décide de venir par une
conférence dans le nez bob pour le
quartier pour aider ces personnes dont
qui viennent y présente qu'est-ce que ça
les panneaux solaires et il montre aussi
comment on peut construire soi même ses
panneaux solaires thermiques
c'est d'ailleurs ce qu'on a fait dans
notre maison ils sont comme made et
voilà donc les gens à peuvent poser
leurs questions ils volaient
concrètement comment ça fonctionne et
oser installés çà chez eux ou encore
jean luc qui est pas vraiment un
économie écologiste dans l'âme les
toitures végétalisées les toilettes
sèches c'est pas vraiment quelque chose
qui lui parle mais les venues voir cette
conférence parce que ça les panneaux
solaires ça lui parlait malheureusement
pour lui il a une envie pressante et du
coup dans le nez bomb
il n'y a que des toilettes sèches donc
il a testé et là il a dû que c'était pas
si différent en fait il y avait même une
douce odeur de sciure et finalement en
fait pourquoi on utilise de l'eau
potable dans nos toilettes c'est pas si
logique que ça parce que oui n'est beau
meuble est aussi un lieu d'expérience ou
encore sa voisine marie qui habite dans
un immeuble un peu plus loin a toujours
rêvé d'avoir un jardin potager mais
malheureusement elle habite dans un
appartement et ben n'a pas la place donc
la ville invitant jardinier à la
retraite à venir vivre un mois d'un est
bob et aider les habitants des
différents immeubles qui ont envie
d'installer empathie jardin potager mais
qui savait pas forcément comment faire
pour faire juste et en accord avec la
ville et les habitants aujourd'hui au
pied de ces immeubles
on a des courgettes des tomates voilà
donc en fait dans cette maison on peut
faire de multiples activités et elle
regroupe toutes ces thématiques
et pour arriver à regrouper toutes les
thématiques et aussi proposer des
solutions sur toutes ces thématiques
on a dû faire une maison un peu
particulière donc et ressemble à ça et
une de ses particularités par exemple
pouvant donner juste une idée c'est que
l'on bloque et complètement productive
donc on a des panneaux solaires qui
servent à produire l'énergie électrique
on a les panneaux solaires thermiques
qui servent à produire l'eau chaude
on récupère au centre la pluie pour la
machine à laver le linge et pour arroser
nos plantes et à l'intérieur de ces
structures
on a des seins verticale on peut
cultiver des plantes ou encore un
sèche-linge solaire mais bon là je vous
parle en fait de
cette maison est derrière ça derrière
cette maison ce projet et toutes ses
idées il ya surtout une équipe une
équipe de cinquante étudiants prêts à
relever tous les défis pour aller en
amérique présenter notre projet au début
ce qui nous a intéressés c'était le côté
multi disciplinaire de travailler avec
des étudiants d'autres domaines
parce que on n'a pas souvent l'occasion
de nos études de le faire mais on n'a
pas pensé qu'on allait devenir
nous-mêmes en fait multifonctions moi je
suis en architecture et je vais la
communication du projet baptiste qui en
sciences de l'environnement se
retrouvent à chercher les fonds pour
construire cette maison ou encore clé ok
génie civil devait expliquer aux
plombiers par où passe exactement les
tuyauteries alors que deux mois avant
elle ne connaissait strictement rien
mais heureusement on est bien entouré
c'est aussi une aventure académique
quatre écoles qui se regroupent avec
toutes sortes de professeurs qui nous
ont cadré qui nous aide qui nous coach
mais aussi en fait des partenaires
institutionnels dont des entreprises qui
viennent on a les apprentis qui viennent
sur le chantier construire avec nous et
ça c'est vraiment un grand partage
d'expériences et demandent eux vit
ensemble on est passionné et pour une
fois aussi les étudiants c'est nous
qu'avant les cartes dont nos mains et
qui faisons tous en recherche les
partenaires on organise les événements
ont
on recherche les entreprises et et ont
construit et on fait même le café parce
qu'on a des travailleurs on travaille le
jour mais la nuit aussi parfois les
jours fériés ou les week-ends d'où le
café c'est très important et on a
surtout super unis parce que c'est ça
qui nous porte
c'est l'esprit d'équipé qui nous fait
aller plus loin et relever tous les
défis
parce que passer en fait de la
conception d'une idée à la réalisation
eh ben on a parfois des problèmes ce qui
est normal mais l'important c'est de
continuer d'avancer
mais plus qu unis on est des amis ça
fait deux ans que toutes nos vacances à
tous tes vacances mais chaque fois
plusieurs semaines pendant les vacances
d'hiver et d'été
on les passe ensemble à faire des
workshops intense on travaille sur le
projet et on vit sous le même toit on
mange ensemble matin midi soir on
partage nos différentes activités comme
la grimpe ou encore le karaoké nand et
qui sont plus concluant que d'autres et
c'est surtout une grande découverte une
découverte du milieu professionnel
une découverte de technologie une
découverte aussi de façon de penser et
de façon de collaborer
on aime bien rire nous arrive aussi
parfois de pleurer ou pleurer de joie
ça dépend des moments parce que c'est
vraiment une expérience super intense
comme aujourd'hui de me retrouver devant
vous on a les désaccords
oui quand on est 50 on n'est pas
toujours tout serait même longueur
d'onde mais l'important c'est la
communication
la communication est un point essentiel
dans ce genre de projet c'est pour ça
qu'on a développé toutes sortes de
plateformes on à what's app mais on a
aussi une plateforme slack google drive
google calendar
oui on veut être sûr en fait que
personne ne loupe rien et qu'on tout le
monde soit au courant de tout ce qui
n'est d'ailleurs pas toujours facile
même avec toutes les plateformes qu'on a
aujourd'hui à disposition
mais un autre point important c'est la
persévérance
parce que oui l'on faut il en faut pour
mener un projet autant important
jusqu'au bout faut jamais baisser les
bras
vous continuez et
il faut se dire qu'on va réussir parce
que après quand on commence à construire
et qu'on voit en fait sous nos yeux à la
force de nos bras
les choses se monte ça vraiment une
un grand bonheur et c'est génial et
c'est surtout une expérience de partage
de partage de connaissances de partage
de moments de vie de partage de façons
de faire on voit que pas tout le monde
fait pareil mais on s'accepte et est
ensemble
ensemble nous 50 étudiants dont moi je
suis une
parmi les autres qui sont là mais qui
sont là avec moi on a décidé de relever
ce défi est de travailler en quatre
écoles suisses différentes avec des
étudiants de domaines différents et de
construire ensemble quelque chose est
d'ailleurs ensuite le présenter aux
états unis et ça c'est pour vous dire
que en fait si on veut on peut agir et
que c'est à nous en fait de décider quel
sera notre habitat du futur
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]